for many people in europe and north
america summer appeared to offer relief
from covid the promise of normal life
returning that respite now appears to be
ending infection rates are rising
intensive care beds are filling up the
vast majority of them with patients who
haven't been vaccinated underlining the
fact that the jab will protect most who
get it from getting anything more than a
mild case of the disease which is why
denmark where more than 80 percent of
those over 12 are fully vaccinated has
now lifted all covid19 restrictions on
the other side of the scale the
developing countries where vaccines are
still in drastically short supply today
we're asking corona and the fourth wave
a pandemic for the unvaccinated
[Music]
welcome to to the point it's a pleasure
to welcome our guests susana schreiber
is with the german ethics commission the
deutsche iterate and she says
vaccination remains the best way to
control the pandemic
it's a pleasure to welcome eric
kirschbaum he works as a freelance
journalist for the la times and the
independent in great britain it's
incomprehensible he says why so many
americans and people in other places
around the world are refusing to get
protected with a proven vaccine
and my colleague benjamin alvarez-gruber
is with us he's been working for dw's
covet special desk he's also a political
correspondent in our berlin bureau and
he's convinced vaccine inequality is
unethical and unwise it will lead to a
prolonged pandemic for everyone
so i'd like to start with a look at
where we are now as we head into fall
here in the northern hemisphere and eric
are the rising numbers that we're seeing
in many places in fact a harbinger of
this dreaded fourth wave and will it
look like the other waves in terms of
overburdened healthcare systems
icu units at their limits and um and
lockdowns
it's pretty discouraging at the moment
in the summer it looked like with the
vaccinations rolling out that we'd be in
a much better position than we are now
but we see in the united states where
only 52 of the people are vaccinated
that the the cases are going way up
again the death rates are going way up
again it's really discouraging the same
thing is happening on a similar scale
smaller scale in germany but there are
some bright spots out there like denmark
which you mentioned where 80 percent of
the people have been vaccinated in the
coronavirus is more or less
on the wane and nearly nearly beaten so
the world is a crazy confusing place
susanna
are we nonetheless even if vaccine rates
aren't where many governments were
hoping they'd be are we nonetheless
seeing a decoupling between the
prevalence of the infection and
overburdened healthcare systems and i'm
thinking particularly of germany's case
germany has just decided recently to
stop relying largely on infection rates
to measure the severity of the pandemic
and to start focusing more on the actual
degree of burden for health care systems
so
what does that tell us are we seeing
vaccines starting to break the cycle of
escalation
well certainly vaccines are very helpful
but nevertheless we still have a
correlation yeah so it's it before it
used to be the case that
we had a certain relation between the
infection numbers and a certain
percentage of people who ended up in
icus for example now this ratio between
number of infected people and people in
icus that is going down but the
correlation is still there so that means
if the numbers are now rising and we can
easily fill up all the icus with the
same absolute numbers as we did before
if we only have if we only let the
infection flow so to speak so yes it was
wise that germany takes that into
account but we cannot get rid of
infection numbers we have to follow them
and it's still a crisis and we still can
up in a situation that's as bad as it
was last year
benjamin clearly all three of you if i
look at your opening statements do
believe that vaccines are crucial to
bringing the pandemic under control yet
in many places the rate of vaccination
absolutely isn't where governments were
hoping that it would be
give us a global overview if you would
is that more about skepticism on the
part of citizens or is it about poor
crisis management by governments
themselves i think it's a mix of both if
we look for example at switzerland where
you're in the western europe countries
you have only 51 or 52 percent
of people who have been vaccinated and
they have the problem of the hospital of
the capacity in the hospitals
so on one side it is clearly when it
comes to crisis management by the
government and on the other side is also
how the vaccine drive is developing if
these countries also get the vaccines in
chile for example i'm from chile and the
vaccine drive has been spectacular there
on one side because there was no
bureaucracy
people could just go with the ideas to
get the job and they had a different
approach to the one that germany has
right now it was not get the people
where the jabs are but the other way
around so take the jabs and take them
where people usually are and that's
something that germany is doing now but
i think it's too late susana that is yes
exactly germany is starting to do that
now why didn't they move toward that far
far sooner we're talking here about
mobile vaccine units that go to sports
events or other places and simply
vaccinate any comer
well i don't know but my personal
interpretation is that in the beginning
when we had the vaccines there was this
shortage and everyone wanted to have it
so the question was how to really get
vaccination and then suddenly within a
month it changed completely right and
that's something that people didn't take
into account and while germany is a bit
slow we are very security oriented
before things change so yes we could
have been a bit faster in implementing
these low threshold methods to get the
vaccines to the people and of course
there are other cases where governments
have been innovative and nonetheless
vaccine levels are not where they should
be just this past march u.s president
joe biden held out the hope that by
independence day on july 4th the u.s
could celebrate its freedom from covid
that hope has proven misplaced the u.s
is once again seeing infections and
death rates soar
vaccination rates also dramatically vary
across regions not least because getting
the job has become a question of
political identity
tonight u.s president biden is planning
drastic measures to increase the
country's vaccination rate
they include mandatory vaccine for
federal employees and strict
requirements for businesses
this is a pandemic of the unvaccinated
and it's caused by the fact that despite
america having unprecedented and
successful vaccination program
we still have nearly 80 million
americans who have failed to get the
shot
to make matters worse
there are elected officials
actively working to undermine the fight
against covet 19.
the governor of florida is one of those
officials he opposes the measures
despite the rising infections in the
republican ruled south
people should not be cast aside because
they make a medical decision for
themselves they should not lose their
job they should not be unable to put
food on their table just because they
made a different decision than the
powers that b are demanding that they
make
get vaccinated
and the us are not alone other countries
are increasing the pressure on the
unvaccinated
will mandatory vaccination help fight
the pandemic
[Music]
and i want to pass that question
straight on to
eric but with an addition if i may
now this maxine mandate that joe biden
has just ordered is due to affect up to
100 million americans that's a lot of
people so the question for me would be
amongst these hundred million there are
undoubtedly quite a few republican
vaccine skeptics
will they comply do you think and what
will be the longer term political
fallout of this act
it's a really good question we don't
really know i mean unfortunately the
united states um vaccinations has become
a political issue some states with
republican governors republican votes
are very low rates well under 40. and
the and the infection rates are going
way up there the death rates are going
way up there was just a story last week
of a 73 year old heart of heart attack
victim who couldn't get a hospital room
because they were all filled with covet
so it's definitely a problem
biden is definitely raising the pressure
he's tried to do the soft approach until
now but he's bringing out the cannons
now he's leveraging the pressure and
he's going pretty much as far as he can
by forcing all federal workers to get
vaccinated and any companies that rely
on federal funds to get vaccinated he's
even reached into the private sector
saying companies with more than 100
people have to either get vaccinated or
get tested every week so he's really
ratcheting up the pressure the nuclear
option at the end of the day is to have
a mandate which the supreme court has
already said the the federal government
has the power to do a mandate but let me
drill deeper on the politics of this
we've
seen a lot of misinformation about
vaccines out there on especially social
media and especially social media that
lean rightward now
some talk show hosts radio talk show
hosts
some people in the right wing
media have actually after getting
infected themselves come around and said
go out and get a vaccine has that made
any difference in republican ranks not a
big difference i mean we're still seeing
i mean the republican governor stood up
right away to tell biden that's not
going to work so it's still a very
political toxic environment the united
states which is unfortunate a lot of
people are going to die because of these
political debates but biden is doing
everything he can to try to raise the
pressure and for biden this is going to
be the signature issue of his whole
first term if he has a second term the
midterm elections will probably be
fought on their corona question it
started looking very good for biden when
he started out with the vaccine going up
but if the united states
keeps dropping the ball the economy is
starting to slow down already biden's
gonna have a big problem next year when
the midterm elections come around
susan let's shift our focus now to
germany because here too we've seen
lagging vaccination rates as we
mentioned and we've seen many people
including many young people
holding out against vaccination
why is that it's not a political issue
in the same way as the u.s is it
it is a little bit of political issue
but not to the same extent
i think we have a certain fraction of
the population that really resist or
reject vaccines on vaccinations but i
think we have a large proportion of
those who simply
don't care too much right who don't see
that they have to take part in it who
didn't have a chance to doing it because
there are no slow threshold offers so i
think we still have potential that we
can recruit more people for the
vaccinations but we have not been very
clever so far in how to achieve that i
want to talk in a moment about how that
potential could perhaps be maximized but
let me first ask you benjamin to speak
to us wearing both of your hats your
german hat and your chilean hat so
starting with germany would you say more
drastic measures are needed here and
would mandates of the type we're seeing
in the u.s would that be a feasible
political tool for germany
i think not feasible as a general
mandate for vaccines you can increase
pressure for certain jobs for example
people working in hospitals or people
working with older people in care
centers who need to get the job but
there are other ways of increasing
pressure i mean now in germany there's
this debate about 2g and 3g
so basically if you have a system with
3g that would get tested so if you have
a test the imf if you have the vaccine
or you need if you recovered from the
disease there would be one part and the
other one with 2g leaving out the people
who have a negative test so that would
also increase pressure on those who have
not
gotten the vaccine
and i think there is a person they
wouldn't be able to go to what movie
theaters for example for restaurants i
mean that's the discussion right now and
as susana just pointed out there is
potential there and it's not wise to
think that those who are unvaccinated
all all anti-vaxxers there's a
percentage there there are surveys also
by the robert [ __ ] institute so by
germany's deceased control agency it
says that some still need the option to
get the job so none of them are
anti-vaxxers there are some of them but
there is still potential there and there
will be important to see how politicians
will be able to increase
not only the pressure but also the
information to them to get the
information and say okay maybe it is a
good good decision to to get the job
myself now let me get you to put your
other hat on and talk to us about chile
because chile in fact has quite an
impressive vaccination right now 80
percent of the population similar to
denmark so two questions briefly how did
they do it and secondly and of course
it's that's not a brief answer but
nonetheless uh if you would and also
will we see chile relax restrictions as
denmark is going to the point of
actually allowing a resumption of normal
life for those who are vaccinated they
are and they will open also the borders
starting in october for tourists who got
their job outside and other countries to
be able to make it into the country i'd
say
what has been a very good point is the
bureaucracy that you can just go and get
the job and that has helped them to go
to a museum to get it in a park to get
it in a church what germany is doing now
and to see okay maybe the vaccine
centers that are closing in berlin
because there are not many people going
there anymore
we need to get the jabs there and of
course to relax them as well i mean
they've been pretty strict with several
things when it comes to for example a
night night curfew in chile that is
still there so they have been really
really strict uh measures in chile and i
always wonder i usually cover this
quivering protest here in germany as
well where they say this is a
dictatorship and you can do anything and
this is a dictatorship
to
show them how the situation is in other
countries where it's really strict where
you can really not leave the house where
like actual actual lockdowns are not
what we've seen here in germany let me
just now go back to susanna with a
question related to that because
we do see
words like freedom
uh taking on enormous
attention here in germany in the context
of the covid debate and
also i think historic references where
we see anti-vaxxers saying they feel
like anna frank
because their freedoms are being
restricted
does that example show us that a
country's history
is absolutely crucial to what kind of
measures are going to work
i'm not sure that that's the right
example with anne frank but the history
of a country certainly matters yeah so i
think the cultural history and the
the the attitudes that people have like
germany has for example a high need for
security right so people in germany want
to have their rules or are used to
having the rules they're used to being
provided with a high degree of safety
and um most of us don't know how
well-off we are if you compare us to
other countries so
in other countries it may be different
perhaps one one example of portugal
where with the vaccinations um they only
had the children's vaccinations against
all kinds of infections um several
decades ago so so the people who still
live in in portugal they have seen how
the death rates among children suddenly
dropped and how beneficial vaccines can
be so i think this is also an historic
reason why now there's a higher
percentage of people who have a positive
attitude what i'm driving at though is
perhaps another aspect
during the nazi era germany had a
government that forced people to submit
to certain medical procedures
that is often given as a reason why a
vaccine mandate here would be very
difficult for politicians to
adopt
i don't know i would bring up the
counter example that in east germany for
example people are very used to you know
getting vaccinations and i think it was
more in west germany where people are a
bit more hesitant nevertheless we now
observe that in particular in the east
of germany um we have more vaccine
hesitance so
i'm not sure that this this comparison
really explains it all
i'd rather say it's a little bit in our
nature and whether that all can go back
to the third reich i'm not i'm not sure
eric clearly trust plays a very central
role in the degree of acceptance uh by
the public of vaccination are there
things that the u.s authorities could
and should have done better to really
win public trust or is polarization such
a black hole that it just sucks up any
such attempt i think political
polarization colors everything in
america it's a cultural war in america
every question seems to be republican or
democrat blue or red there's no way
around it but in germany i think
incentives
could work i think germans need more
incentives i think germany needs more
role models the united states could use
more role models dolly parton people
rolling up their sleeves getting the jab
if soccer players in germany soccer
stars or musicians like helena fisher
would suddenly get vaccinated i think
that would do it a lot i think they
should even give incentives free broad
first or even 100 euros for everybody
who gets vaccinated now that will
probably get the german rate up a lot
higher a lot faster than the mandate can
i just ask you um also because you've
been watching german politics for a long
long time interestingly enough we have
federal elections around the corner here
we have all three of the main party's
chancellor candidates
saying there will never be a lockdown
again for those who are vaccinated
is that realistic do you think and are
you surprised that there's so much
consensus among the mainstream
politicians not really because they're
all in the same government now anyway at
least the two of the three candidates
they're all in the grand coalition
i've been surprised that the corona
issue has been sort of been
blocked out of the election campaign
it's sort of a loser subject nobody
wants to touch right now that's why
there won't be
fees for testing until after the
election things like that the the cruel
measures the the tougher steps will be
coming after the election in october
which is a good thing that'll help
probably raise raise the levels as well
susanna you mentioned a moment ago
children and
i'd like to ask you should we be
encouraging vaccination for kids the
pandemic has kept 1.5 billion young
people out of school and especially in
poor countries but also in rich ones
yes no that's indefinite yes from my
side we should encourage children and to
be vaccinated in particular the ones in
germany now over 12 because that's where
authorities said yes that's that's safe
to do that also the standing commission
so the committee responsible for
vaccination recommendations said and
that children should get that and yes
usually a counter argument is that
children are less vulnerable so so they
don't suffer as many
yeah
difficult cases but on the other hand we
have a high number of children
nevertheless who have this multi-organ
um inflammation for example which they
can develop in response to covide and um
i'd like to just give two numbers and
then i'll stop that's if we had half a
million children who were infected and
that's about in may and we had 350 of
those who suffered then from this
multi-organ disease if we now do the
comparison and we would vaccinate half a
million children and 350 would have to
go to intensive care unions because of
the vaccination everyone would say stop
that but if it's the virus which you
know can have long-term effects which we
don't know yet and so on then people
seem to care less and i don't understand
it personally because the mathematics of
it are very clear yeah so so how to take
the decision
let us take a closer look at vaccine
inequality because while rich countries
have stocks of vaccine large enough to
start offering booster shots to those
willing to get vaccinated in many
countries of the global south vaccines
remain in short supply our next report
takes us to kenya
three members of this family have died
of covert 19.
it happened very quickly says james
muangi who lost his father uncle and
grandmother in a matter of days
we are traumatized
because it's not so easy some people you
are with them tweets ago they had no
issue
then all of a sudden
in a span of less than 10 days they're
all gone
according to the world health
organization only two percent of the
african population is vaccinated
the number of deaths is proportionately
high
we cannot start administering booster
shots
when
some of us
don't even know if we will be able to
get a second shot it's just
a really great injustice and it's
unfortunate that who's hands are also
tied
the who assures there are enough doses
to vaccinate at least health workers and
the elderly yet so far too few have been
administered
how important is it to fight the
pandemic globally
and benjamin your opening statement made
it clear you think it's very very
important to fight it globally when last
you were on this show in june we
observed that although politicians in
europe and north america love to pay lip
service to that mantra that no one is
safe till everyone is safe they have not
been honoring the principle in practice
have you seen any change in the last few
months not really and one of the big
problems we just heard in the report the
who the world health organization are
sure that they are enough doses but
they're not a charity and they don't
have any political power so the rich
countries will of course vaccinate their
people first and then they will hand
over jobs to poorer countries and that's
one of the big big problems here eric
frankly the u.s is amongst the laggards
in many ways its contribution to the
international kovacs initiative that's
supposed to guarantee global access to
vaccines hasn't been much larger than
germany's it's given 110 doses 110
million doses germany's given a hundred
million and is considerably smaller and
less rich than the u.s why doesn't
president biden walk his multilateralist
talk
that's a good question he's talked about
100 500 million doses but the united
states is right there in middle america
and south america with new variants like
the moo coming up so united states is
very vulnerable to
coming back from around the world
hopefully the united states will will
lead the way and get the world to donate
more to other countries
susanna this week the wh show issued a
report on kovacs's achievements in its
first year it's exactly one year since
it was uh formed and it the report says
this and i quote the global picture of
access to covet 19 vaccines is
unacceptable only 20 percent of people
in lower income countries have received
a first dose compared to 80 percent in
higher income countries is that
ethically defensible
is it could you make an argument as many
politicians do that they have a duty to
protect their own populations first
regardless of what's happening in the
rest of the world
not really it's really important to to
get the world vaccinated
i can come up with a practical argument
that it would be very difficult for
would have been at least in germany very
difficult for politicians as vaccines
were still very scarce here than then to
take them and distribute them in the
world so they also have to think about
their re-election and it may have given
up uproars in in
in the population um but ethically no we
have to make sure that the world gets
vaccinated there's no way around it
and you mean experts are saying that
kovacs won't really be able to ramp up
its efforts until well into 2022 what
does that mean for the global economy is
health inequality also an economic risk
including for rich countries could we
maybe make the argument on on the basis
of self-interest it will it will if it's
not on the basis of solidarity to help
them as well and that's why in my
opening statement i said unwise because
it's not only when it comes to the
pandemic that i mean if we have large
parts of the world still operating as a
variant factory these variants will come
back and then also hit the rich
countries and the same happens with the
economy if we have a lot of big
economies who are not able to recover
from this pandemic then that will hit
everyone
eric given where we are today
must we acknowledge that corona isn't
going away anytime soon and learn to
live with an ongoing pandemic at least
amongst the unvaccinated yeah definitely
if i were unvaccinated i'd be a little
bit nervous right now but i like to look
at countries like denmark where the
glass is half full where they're going
to be living with corona but in a
smaller scale it's not going to mess up
everybody's lives anymore but yeah
corona is going to be here for a long
long time as it was the spanish flew 100
years ago it didn't go right away either
didn't go away right away either and
susanna just a last brief quote from the
atlantic magazine it said that the
vaccination gap between wealthy
democracies and the rest of the world is
turbocharging inequality and could lead
to a permanent two-tier world where we
have the safe in the rich world and and
the unsafe in the poor world do you
think that's really where we're heading
i'm more optimistic i think it takes
more time more time than it should but i
think we will get the world vaccinated
and definitely the vulnerable ones in
the other countries we're all working on
that and certainly western governments
are too
thank you thanks for those optimistic
last words thanks to all of you for
being with us here in the studio and
thanks to you for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
you